bien le dernier trailer de star wars 9
que nous a proposée disney est vraiment
incroyable et bourré d'informations
comme le veut la tradition et puis nous
sommes quand même sur le trailer final
du dernier film de la saga principale
est bas nous allons l'analyser et
théorisé dessus évidemment nous
commençons sur l'image de ré balançant
un casque avant de partir dans la forêt
j'ai d'abord cru que c'était le casque
qu'elle possédait dans l'épisode 7 mais
pas du tout il semblerait que ce soit un
casque de pilote ou d'entraînement si
j'ai cru ceux ci c'est parce que ray
semble s'affirmer énormément dans ce
dernier opus est la symbolique de
balancer le casque d'après moi souligne
l'émancipation de ré qui devient une
véritable jedi comparer aux 7 ou son
casque servait justement à se renfermer
sur elle même et avoir le sentiment
d'être caché ce principe d'émancipation
peut également être traduit par
l'accomplissement ray semble toujours
s'entraîner sur ce qui me semble être la
lune forestière d'andorre et comme pour
l'entraînement de l'udc dans la trilogie
d'origine le casque pourrait servir pour
seulement masquer la vision de ré et le
fait de jeter ce casque pourrait
symboliser la fin de son entraînement
qu'elle est prête à accomplir son destin
d'où le fait qu'elle se met à courir à
travers la jungle pour atterrir sur ce
qui semble être les débris de l'étoile
de la mort un peu à la manière dan solo
nous avons un film qui nous parle en
arrière-plan de la force et du peu qu'il
en connaît je le compare à un solo par
rapport à sa position dans le film fine
est un grand résistant mais loin de la
force comme le fut en solo en quelque
sorte tout comme l'interprétation que
nous avions de lui dans le set
les jedi le côté obscur tout ça c'est
vrai mais c'est un discours très malin
car fine est en train de motiver les
troupes pour un conseil de guerre tout
en amenant ce parallèle à la force avec
la sensation l'instinct maintenant que
la résistance et l'espoir est relancé il
faut quelqu'un pour les guider nous
sommes clairement dans une suite logique
du huitième opus
détail important à souligner c'est que
rose est toujours présente et jouera bel
et bien dans l'opus 9 je n'étais pas
spécialement fan du personnage mais
l'actrice avait reçu bon nombre d'
insulte qui n'avait pas lieu d'être
donc c'est une belle réponse qu'elle
soit là toujours dans cette idée
d'émancipation et d'affirmation de ré la
dernière des jedi affirme que tout le
monde croit la connaître
alors qu en fait personne ne la connaît
vrai
personnellement cela sonne ici comme le
fait que ray a le droit d'être en colère
a le droit de mettre ses espoirs en key
lorraine comme elle le fit dans
l'épisode 8 qu'elle ne soit pas obligé
d'être la jedi parfaite la justice hier
que tout le monde attend elle n'a pas
connu ses parents elle n'a pas de réelle
identité elle est poussée au devant de
la scène par tout le monde
c'est pourquoi key lorraine montrer
comme une sorte de miroir de ré la
comprend et la connaît il comprend ses
douleurs il comprend sa position
leur combat sur les débris de l'étoile
de la mort est pour moi symbole de leur
relation ils se cherchent et essaye de
se comprendre
c'est personnellement ce que je vois
pourquoi cas l or n irais perdre son
temps à retrouver ray dans les débris de
l'étoile de la mort alors qu'il pourrait
tout simplement essayé d'écraser la
résistance avec son armée qui
apparemment viennent de trouver
d'anciens vaisseau imperio congelés
petite parenthèse pour souligner ce plan
de ré chewbacca fine et pau dans le
faucon millenium référence à la première
trilogie où nous voyons and avec la
princesse leia luc échoue oui nous
arrivons donc aux dires de palpatine
longtemps j'ai attendu
ceci prouve que sidious étaient présents
depuis le début dans cette trilogie
et comme pour sur le poster promotionnel
ce dernier regarder depuis l'ombre
l'avancement de l'histoire et le
développement de ré écailles lorraine et
comme je le soulignais dans mon droit
théorique d'ailleurs je vous invite à
regarder car elles concordent beaucoup
avec ce qui est montré pour le moment
ray et kayes lorraine semble agir
ensemble
eux qui sont depuis le début mis en
confrontation ont enfin compris qu'ils
devaient agir ensemble pour avancer
l'époque des jedi contre les sites est
révolue pour justement atteindre un
entre deux et comme démontré par sidious
le fait d'agir ensemble les mèneront à
leur perte
palpatine et contrerait mais aussi
caille lorraine et ces derniers devront
agir ensemble pour pouvoir le défaire
passons maintenant à lacets nous
apparaît c-3po et semble effectuer une
mission sacrifice nous pouvons
clairement faire le rapprochement avec
une des images proposées dans le
précédent trailer ou 6 3 p o avait les
yeux rouges comme je vous l'affirmé
également la saga doit prendre fin
il faut pour moi que le symbole de r2d2
c3po soit clôturée et notamment avec la
mort d'un des deux droïdes
cela semble être le cas avec c3po qui
regarde une dernière fois ses amis avant
de potentiellement se sacrifier pour la
cause
il est possible comme le montrent ces
images que nos héros et réussi à
s'introduire dans le camp ennemi pour
exploser au prendre le contrôle de la
source avant que possiblement rennes par
ailleurs certainement retrouver caille
lorraine ce n'est qu'une supposition
l'udc reprend la parole en font sur des
scènes de préparation pour la guerre de
la résistance nous pouvons souligner
l'arrivée du personnage de jannah
incarnée par naomi acquis ou encore le
retour de billy dee williams qui
rejouera lando calrissian mais allons au
plus intéressant nous sommes de nouveau
face au duo de calais lorraine et aurait
certainement en train d'échanger après
leur combat
la mise en scène rappelle énormément
game of thrones dans sa conception
notamment avec ces deux personnages au
sommet d'une gloire passée
l'image est très belle je trouve nous
avons également la présence de fines qui
comme un grand frère pour s inquiète
pour elle et la suie peu importe le
danger sauf que nous ne sommes plus en
présence de lames aimerait qui décide
aujourd'hui de s'affirmer et travailler
aux côtés de calais lorraine pour ce
dernier épisode comme nous le montre
l'image suivante fine semble s'inquiéter
de ce duo là où il ya mon
incompréhension c'est que ray et calais
lorraine détruisent à deux ensembles une
sorte de statut et on dirait qu'elle
représente dark vador j'avoue avoir
tiqué un moment dessus quand j'ai vu le
trailer mais les débris nous semblent
montrer les restes du casque du seigneur
déchu j'espère me tromper
personnellement et que cette destruction
était autre chose mais dans la
symbolique et lorraine a toujours
conseillé arrêt de faire abstraction du
passé jusqu'à même tuer le passé si
besoin il veut défaire sith et jedi pour
apporter un nouveau monde
alors que pourtant il ya toujours été
motivé par les travaux de son grand père
il est ici une belle contradiction
contradictions qui si c'est bel et bien
une statue représentant dark vador
pourrait être anéantie pour montrer
l'évolution également de kay lorraine
enfin comme dans tout trailer la scène
finale est toujours là plus impactante
déjà nous sommes je pense face à
benneteau l'eau et non caille lorraine
sur cette image
de par l'expression sur son visage je ne
vois aucune colère et le fait qu'ils ne
portent pas son casque qui l'a pourtant
refabriquer en dit long et dans la mise
en scène on dirait qu'ils sont le
vouloir et des raies qui est face à
l'empereur dans la scène suivante
empereur que nous voyons enfin pour la
première fois et c'est important de le
souligner ce dernier n'est toujours pas
présent sur les affiches ou encore le
poster finale de star wars 9 lui-même
sidious agit dans l'ombre
hélas le plus surprenant arrive lui qui
parle en font depuis maintenant 3
trailer n'est pas juste une voix de
narration comme ça le laissait
sous-entendre mais semble bel et bien
aux côtés de ray depuis le début en tant
que force ghost nous le voyons carey
semble réagir à ce que dit ce dernier
alors qu'elle a l'air totalement perdu
et sous l'émotion la voix de l'eia vient
encore plus nous surprendre car il
semblerait qu'elles puissent également
être présente en tant que fantôme de la
force elle qui semble devenir une sorte
de mer pour la jedi
les trois protagonistes de la première
trilogie ont tous été comme une sorte de
parents pourraient exactement comme le
souligne michael oren dans l'opus huit
en tout cas si les ja est un fantôme de
la force cela signifie que son
personnage est malheureusement décédé
mais ce n'est pas réellement une
surprise car ils fischer nous a
malheureusement quittés il ya plus d'un
an et dans la conception des trois films
de la trilogie
l'opus est tourné beaucoup autour de
hann solo se terminant sur sa mort
pareil pour l'udc avec l'épisode 8 et
bien évidemment l'opus neuf et est donc
dédié à l'eia j'aimerais également
souligné la non présence des chevaliers
de rennes dans ce trailer cela va faire
maintenant 3 trailer teaser qu'ils sont
absents et pourtant nous savons qu'ils
sont dans le film est ce que finalement
l'idée a été un petit peu mise de côté
ces derniers représenteront seulement un
simple garde prétorienne port cahier
lorraine ou bien risque disney souhaite
vraiment cacher quelque chose par
rapport à ces derniers a vous de me dire
mais j'espère que la vidéo vous aura plu
n'hésitez vraiment pas aller voir le 3
théorique j'ai fait sur star wars neuf
car les théories se concrétise vraiment
de plus en plus notamment par rapport à
ce dernier trail
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à laisser
un pouce bleu et un commentaire on se
retrouve dans la semaine pour d'autres
vidéos en attendant c'était argot rock
et que le liner ce soit avec vous
[Musique]